all right I've got something really
exciting to announce we are starting to
develop a new miniseries you might
remember a couple months ago we had the
critical thinking miniseries where we
went through the structure of arguments
the validity and soundness of arguments
explaining different logical fallacies
including ad hominem begging the
question and all sorts of other really
great material it went really really
well
and we now have started to move forward
on a new miniseries which I would argue
is going to do as well or even better
than the critical thinking miniseries
and it is a pseudoscience miniseries we
are going to be looking at roughly 12
different pseudo-sciences and talking
about their Genesis their background
debunking them as nothing more than
pseudoscience or basically charlatans
Ari is it charlatans your charlatan ISM
I don't actually know yeah I think maybe
we'll cover that in an upcoming
mini-series on what words are actually
words but this is going to be a mini
series on pseudoscience and as an
example we've got one topic will be
astrology a lot of people are going to
get angry another topic will be Reiki
personal favorite of mine we will do
psychics
we're gonna do a whole bunch of stuff
but I want to bring you in to help us
choose some of those topics that we're
going to be doing so like psychics will
definitely be one Reiki will definitely
be one astrology will definitely be one
but there's some where I actually want
to go by what the audience wants so
we're tying this into a poll that any
YouTube sponsors can vote in okay
YouTube sponsorship is a beta program
that is only some YouTube channels are
participating we have been asked and we
have chosen to participate this is
something that you are able to click the
blue sponsor button on our YouTube
channel homepage as well as on any
individual video that will then allow
you to become a sponsor for $4.99 a
month okay that $4.99 a month gets you
sponsors only posts on the community tab
that is where we will be posting a poll
we're our sponsors we'll get to decide
by voting which of these different
possible pseudoscience topics do you
want us to cover there's other great
sponsorship benefits including that you
get custom I guess we would call them
badges custom badges next to your
username in comments and live chats and
those badges become more and more cool
based on how long you've been a sponsor
and lots of other great stuff we're
looking at developing custom emojis for
our YouTube sponsors that can be used in
chat it's all fantastic but in the short
term what I'm saying is we've got a
pseudo-science miniseries coming up you
can vote on which topics we will include
in the miniseries if you become a
youtube sponsor for $4.99 a month go
over to the community tab on our
homepage
YouTube homepage after becoming a
sponsor vote and we will have the final
list to present to you very very soon